how's it going bros today I'm gonna rate
and eat every single candy and with me
as a guest is
hi
Joey the anime man it's me
let's go
finally we found one that's open all
right stock up everything
everything
not everything
everything this is where I need your
like expertise to find the good stuff
yeah of course all of them
but don't tell me which ones are fitting
okay so they have some old school Kenny
okay what the is that that's hard
candy yeah that's for old people yeah
sorry old people
you're old
already
okay sure
yeah let's go they got Super Mario Chris
Pratt oh my God it's great dude I don't
understand why these are popular here
they suck
this is wrong we're gonna have a few
today
for sure if that's what you like which
came to me the right one looks better
this one yeah
so these are like the really cheap
traditional kind of candies they all
look the same
that looks great
this is breakfast lunch and dinner
wow that is so much candy I'm gonna die
today why did you do this to me you're
the expert any mean Candyman yep that's
my name now where's that moment to help
him yeah thanks
[Laughter]
where should we begin we're gonna rate
them all in Joey I don't know what which
ones have you had and which ones have
you not had is the real question I feel
like I've had most of these and these
they suck really yeah they're awful you
like them
they're all right
not too bad okay which one just why did
you buy these because these are golden
Japanese game here these are actually
good okay which one speaks to you the
most oh okay I don't know okay this is
ridiculous what is it
oh this one takoyaki yeah you picked one
that requires like a 12-step program all
right yeah I mean not doing that we have
enough tea these are pretty basic
these you can get anyway these are
kajuguni or like juice Gumi made from
100 fruit juice oh yeah they're big on
that in Japan yeah the fruit juice yeah
there you go all right
the first one will be right in these
actually slob spoilers don't spoil it
you've had these before no I haven't
yeah they're good yeah right because of
the fruit juice yeah yeah it's 100 fruit
juice
okay it doesn't tastes like chemically
and weird yeah hell yeah yeah you just
say fresh that's probably a beat here
for me only a b orange is kind of lame
all right what are you rating it I'll
give that like an A okay that's like a
solo day all right I'm gonna this is my
list icing
this is not a democracy I do not take
any responsibility for any of the
injuries actually just because of that
it's CTA wow yes orange Sun Seafood cool
right
laughs
yes thank you for saving me there
because I cannot reading
no you didn't oh you didn't you didn't
do the best part about these things what
I'll show you you're not flaming
look at that means whistle what
are you gone
oh shaking out
damn it
sorry is there chewing gum yeah all
right
that's fine
fun for the whole family
okay I ate two
players
are you are we judging these off like
flavor or just like overall enjoyment
clearly it's overall enjoyment
because you rated these higher than
those hey tears okay you know I'll
accept that
I'm glad we could come to him finally
finally something we can agree on it
fun as hell
wrong
it's going down to me tears killing me
what's something I've never had before
wait you had all of these you definitely
not had these what is this uh bro I grew
up on clothes excuse you are you judging
me because it's pretty Cure today
all right
yeah oh nice it's just for jelly but it
has pretty cute can't go wrong with
pretty girls am I right Joey
they are swell
why do they have to do that
wait so what is this exactly they're
just like little fruit jelly cups I
guess that you can just like take a shot
oh yeah
shot shot shot shot shot shots cute oh
what it's jelly yeah I dude you re the
fact it literally says fruit jelly
you didn't even say come by
boy
[Music]
you don't like that you don't like jelly
garbage devil food
sf2 can we go lower detail yeah I've got
detail actually I'll be generous oh wow
how generous of you poor poor Japanese
children who had to grow up eating this
garbage but what did you grow up eating
good candy no
it was good all right let's drink the
Harry about that you don't like Harry
Potter
these are the best
oh yeah that's an S2
this is like
in Sweden's like the weakest candy you
can get well we're not in Sweden
Phillies we're in Japan we don't have to
match candy no they don't I was hoping
Japan would change my mind sorry German
candy sucks
I like your candy Germany did Haribo
have that annoying slogan like how do
you produce
that sounds annoying yeah I don't know
what they're saying Haribo tastes the
best it makes life to a party kids and
grown-ups love it I don't think so
Germany get out of here
take your stinky candy all right you
want to try us here okay do you want to
try some like dagashi give me some good
yeah that guy which is traditional
Japanese candy that's pretty
no
this sucks there you go look there's two
for us cheers yay am I gonna lose my
Presbyterian license what is this oh
it's uh I think it smells good oh it's
fish so it's fine you're good you're
still an epic pescatarian nice
I love anagi why do it is kind of like
the consistency of cardboard
I did nothing to that
gold strong jawline
yeah
there you go
that's weird the flavor is good I'm
eating a meal I'm eating a candy it
tastes like if you got a piece of
cardboard and you just like soaked it in
sauce yes it does it's really really
really does the consistency is like
eating carbs yeah no joke
how do you write that
it's not barricade the flavor is good
why are you licking your fingers that's
a good sign it's just because I don't
want to make a mess that's a detour I'm
sorry I'm sorry the more you chew on it
the more it's just like
like paper yeah yeah that's really bad
actually yeah I think it's gone down
that's really gross dude can we eat
something good please sure
these are good
chibi sour gummies chibi salad the salad
oh I know you're epic pescetarian but
come on bro so we have four flavors we
have Coke lemon squash I love lemon
spine melon soda or dominant okay I'm
ready for it I love sour candy these are
really good actually I want to get the
lemon yeah yeah
all right
mmm okay yeah all right these are dark
now we're back now we're back now we're
back all right
ah it's so small yeah oh they're not
really that sour though no no does it
have a weird aftertaste yeah
what is that I don't know I don't like
it it's like chemically off the toast
yeah CT was that your that was your
trump card I thought it was but
apparently not all right chibi sours CPA
all right what do we got
cotton candy in a
in a bag in a bag yeah
have you had this I have yes bro you eat
it what that's so cool it's like a
pillow
that's actually kind of sick
that's awesome
it's pretty awesome
well I've no cotton candy so long yeah
this is pretty good it's really good
I think we have a new supreme well new
supreme
all right that's A2 then that's very
sweet it's not related to your bread it
was just fun it was just fun it's new
supreme
all right
oh okay I know one that's actually
pretty good tacos yeah
yeah so the toughness in you for the
boys
only all girls watching have to leave
right now and come back alpha males
Rejoice so you got Coke flavored soda
flavor or energy drink flavor energy
drink flavor I love Energy Drink You
Love energy drinks speaking of which cut
to this Joey's and I'm gonna read
today's sponsor
thank you Joey G fuel sponsor G fuel is
running their first big BOGO sale of the
year
you got seven days from March 15. don't
wait I know you wait and then you're
like ah where'd he go don't go now
actually finish video starting on St
Patrick's Day G fuel is unvolting they
dug deep they listen to what people's
favorite is green sour apple is that
green apple was the flavors that got me
hooked on G fuel it's it's beautiful
you'll love it sour just makes it
makes it sour sour PewDiePie not me the
drain this is an addition that we did
that sold out because it's the greatest
flavor of all time it's taken the
classic PewDiePie flavor and adding sour
to it it's sour linger Berry which is
already the greatest flavor and making
it even better perfecting Perfection
baby sour PewDiePie you're not gonna
want to miss this one it's
foreign
it's also green now we should call it
jacksepticeye flavor I don't know if
you'll approve of that with the bogus
sale you obviously you buy one
you get one yes you can choose between
hype songs very good Naruto Sage Mode
love it it's white peach Mega Man's
flavor actually love that I like all the
flavors what am I saying I actually
really like vegan rice too world of
warcraft's dragon fury and Battletoads
zits Jews it's a great chance for you to
stock up on some g-fuel and save some
money and try out some new flavors no
code is necessary and use the link in
the description that's all you gotta do
and if you're real fast within the first
48 hours if you order more than 70
dollars you get a free shaker
that's pretty good as you guys know I
love G fuel I'm not just selling you
guys something
I wouldn't use myself I drink it every
day it's absolutely delicious I love all
the different flavors I love how easy it
is to just mix with water so I don't
always have to stock up on energy drinks
it just gives you that nice smooth
throughout the day you know whatever
you're doing gaming something physical
or just need extra brain use G fuel back
to video all right this is like that's
the cocoa yeah
hmm
these are pretty good oh
there you can tell they're a level up
from the chibi baby candy yeah these are
tough dummy it's tough they're a little
more sour which I think we were missing
I think so yeah they're pretty pretty
good actually oh yeah those are good you
can get those anywhere as well I feel a
bit embarrassed buying this why because
you want to see them top no they would
think I want to see in town
nah
you ain't tough if you eat these Japan
does a lot of that like mail marketing
and they're like the cringiest way
possible for my male audience those are
good actually genuinely good yeah
all right you're superb new supreme oh
yeah I saw these they were like yogurty
oh yeah
these are all good yogurt
in English oh
excellent they look like a Band-Aid
package yeah you should you should see
what packaging they're coming
excellent
okay is that it all right let's go no oh
my God it keeps going
they like pills
they went from Band-Aids to hitting
pills
crack them open dude that's crazy
take your two a day
you go bro thank you
there's also the lemon ones and the coke
ones of these but I think yogurt ones
are the best that's really
goody is like it's automatic here for
like a little crunchy oh okay it's got
calcium in it what
healthy that's why they make it like a
nutritious and delicious that's gonna be
worth an st all right
you think so oh I don't know no
it was pretty good I had one and I'm
like I'm good now
right I mean I could have a novel I
don't so wow do you want another I'm
good you can't have one another
v-tier what do you think Joy
well my opinion clearly matters
gummy rings although you can play around
with it what
what I feel like cool like rubber band
tricks with it
I'm ready I don't think I've had these
before it has some dumb gimmick that's
how you win me over immediately yeah
immediately too there you go well I need
two to make the dump truck all right
fine thank you all right
let's see who can do it the wackiest
thing ever okay
this is gonna be crazy
you said the wackiest thing and that's
why my fingers really smooth after that
I don't know what is that it's pretty
good
it's Cola flavor isn't it Cola and soda
oh like raminated too but yeah I don't
hate it but I'm gonna give it a beat too
it's all right yeah it's all right
would I buy it again no
next what's up I don't know I'm gonna
show them for it it's Korean I was like
what the this is ASMR on it oh no
should we just try it yeah give it a go
you gotta do some ASMR it says it on the
packaging you have to do it why does it
say ASMR on it baby
did I make noise what is that it's
really gummy all right you get this mic
I'll get this mic
and here we go
oh
because she's actually shocked
you know
there's the Arizona you're missing out
get it
oh wait it has to be sexual
weird I'm not
how was it that was a weird experience I
think we made it
because intended no no
it's not great flavor with sprinkles on
it it was all right it's called rainbow
jelly probably CTO yeah I give that like
a c or and it's not Japanese so it goes
to D2 so there's oh I've tried these
this is that water this is water gummies
water gummy yeah
all right Japan is so high-tech I'm
actually gummies out of water is that it
apparently so I mean look at it it's
like seafood yeah you're right but it's
great so it's delicious and gentle yeah
deliciousness is gentleness oh okay
that's their mortar oh
nice set oh wow that's very grapey
you like gummies a lot in Japan don't
you yeah
don't be specifically you love gummies I
love gummies I get what they're going
for like this like
Blissful experience but it doesn't
honestly it doesn't taste that much
considering how much you smell no I was
hoping for like that water droplet sound
effect that you're seeing like the
attitude I think they hyped it up too
much yeah like though
that's it
that's him yeah that was good they
shouldn't get you there yeah
[Laughter]
Andrew put ASMR on it yeah let's see Tim
yeah these are height I feel they went
with a gimmick and they it didn't really
like to live up it's cool though all
right let's see this is all Gummy all
right here we go here's something
different this is not a candy
potato fry
oh wow oh geez what are these it's sweet
potato I think I didn't read it they're
like same day
um
they're pretty good
wow that might have been the best one
you get like three but
only 62 calories look yo let's go fried
chicken flavor that's why it's good yeah
my pescatarianism no they're actually
really good
these are really good
new supreme
I would say yes Tim well pretty
delicious you like Savory I don't know
just
you know the sweets guys I don't know
why it's just unfortunate because we're
doing this video all right maybe we'll
find some then I see Chris Pratt and I
get immediately excited
yo is that who's playing Luigi
uh I don't know
Leonardo DiCaprio
all right you want Chris Brown Leo yeah
I'll give you both okay oh two different
flavors oh wow so Chris Pratt is Coke
flavored yeah more more cooked flavored
gummy guys well apparently you can also
if you're lucky you can get got me a
shape you can get different rare gummies
you can get rare gummies then we get the
rare gummy
I didn't wait what's that that's Yoshi
oh yeah
who's Brown well did we get the rare
gummies all right
yes
holy we got rare gummies which ones
you get Yoshi and the star oh
I'm so excited
eating all this chemically oh my God all
right do we have anything that's not
gummy anything is not going we got that
isn't Savory food we got the king okay I
got a lot of flag for eating these and
saying I hate them you don't like the
Bible I had the corn flavor of my bowl
no that was weird the the takoyaki
flavor is the best one okay maybe I
should try that have the top way okay
and they work for me and then this is
the this is the teriyaki burger
so it just means flavor or stick it
means good stick good steak tasty stick
about to eat a PVC pipe
Denton
no to be honest like these were good
when I was a kid but
only because you can get one for like 10
Yen oh wow so like you know they were
like 40 Man
man
it's growing on me a little bit actually
you know I thought it was so strong in
the beginning definitely better than the
corn though yeah I don't know why you
had the corner for the first time I
don't know
come on it's for clearly for kids no
adults eat it too I've never seen a
nanole eat it adults on a budget all
right
don't judge for poor people I will not
be part of you sorry all right what else
do we have okay let's try these I've
never had these These are drinkable
jellies because Japan loves jellies for
some reason Coke flavored or soda
flavored I'll do their soda flavor so
usually I got the cokes on okay
I've never even seen these before Oh my
yeah yeah it just came right away didn't
it it just wow it just so
do you want a tissue damn it's really
like
some people just had that issue
I'm embarrassed
um
that's really good yeah yeah
you know I hate jelly but they have
these everywhere in Japan like the
drinkable jelly yeah the drinkable jelly
is quite good
because it's not so slushy as regular
jelly the coke one has like kind of
tastes like chocolate Oh weird am I
tripping can you try that okay it's it
kind of tastes like chocolate
oh that's a weird cold flavor yeah it's
like a chocolatey Coke yeah that's
weird I don't know if I like
that this one's better
[Music]
hmm yeah this one's a lot better yeah
all right I'll give that a beat too what
are you saying I agree so okay great
this is so much fun
all right well I think we're about a
third way through speed up I'm waiting
for now
I'm exhausted all right come on this is
all the way from Iraq all the way from
Morocco definitely it's got a cute
little otter on mine you can't see it
but I'm enjoying it
that's weird I think the last time I had
this I was like five oh what yeah
mmm
it's pretty nice yeah it's pretty good
it kind of tastes like whipped cream
yeah really sweet whipped cream
like with cream with sugar in it super
sugary whipped cream that's nice
beats here
has absolutely zero complaints B2 all
right fine fine B plus
you call me back and be pleased mindset
would love these I'll buy this for him
yeah and these are so cheap too these
are also like 10 20 Yen they have to be
their air yeah since we're gonna
have a kid I need to show them what what
the good stuff is sure sure the first
thing you're gonna do to when you see
your newborn son is you're gonna show
them this video and be like it's on if
you don't eat the goated ones you're
dead to me if you like the umaye ball
I'm smacking it out of your hand
what else looks fancy to you any candy
that's not gummy at this point I'm so
sick all right it's all got me it's all
gummies God you love gummy don't you
okay what is this this looks crazy
do you want to make this sure okay I
need some water
I mean we can try it
why don't you uh why don't you make this
why don't you make this what come sit
down come sit down
I'll show you how to make oh yeah so
this is called chikugashi or like
educational candy because it teaches
kids how to work for their food oh they
don't get that handed to you you
got to work you gotta work for it well
one says one on it yep so put number one
into the team so pour the number one
into the ball
and it needs to be children
as yeah oh I see so the water has the
water got it
did you just try and pour water that
wasn't in no
no
stop mixing it what mix it up get rid of
all the water there you go
this is so awesome and then while he's
making
the number two powder also known as king
really okay yeah yeah and now watch huh
White's blue it's Sweden color now watch
what happens when you mix it or if you
mix blue with yellow it turns orange
supposed to be green why is it not green
oh there we go yeah yeah blue keep going
all right you know done whip that boy up
yeah boy now that that's whipped up you
get the third and final bag what
this is awesome
this is definitely
a nest you're coming if it tastes and
now what you do is you take a spoonful
of that you dip it into the candy and
you have you had this in yes I grew up
on this
all right
what
I never said it tasting good though
pretty nice though yeah yeah could you
imagine being five years old if you did
anything this stuff yeah
that'd be the coolest I was on a steady
diet of these when I was like five
research tastes very sugary for sugary
foam and then you dip it in like
something yeah cheesecake and a candy
yeah all right maybe I'll give it a name
here okay
foreign Island
sounds weird out of context do you want
to tell people more content so momotaro
is like a folklore story in Japan of a
boy who was born out of a giant peach
right and he that's the most as much as
I knew yeah and what he does is he goes
to he he wants to go defeat the Oni in
the island of the Oni okay but he needs
help so what the ubachar does the old
woman does that raises him he makes him
go which is this stuff and he gives it
to certain animals and then the animals
come along and they all fight in the
island they fight and they win that's
you know yeah why does it look like that
oh it's the packaging yeah
I don't remember looking like that this
is definitely like old school yeah
what do you eat the paper no are you
sure you're just too strong
I know no you eat the paper no you don't
eat the paper all right be my guest
I'm telling you you eat the paper I
swear to God I think he just ate paper
best paper hold on let me see this the
paper let me see never mind you eat it
as it is you eat the paper give me the
paper
[Music]
gummy Burger that's this isn't even
Japanese it's Yuppie we didn't rate it
sorry uh beat here or an eight here
because it kills demons
that's cool it doesn't kill these what
do they do then it makes the animals
follow you
wasn't the point to go to in the island
and yeah but he gives those he gives
that to the animals and that's it I'm
confused I don't understand whatever
this is from this is from Indonesia
Indo Bros it's not your time oh this is
the one that comes with the card right
yes I've actually bought these really
because there was cute anime girl whoa
is that a ram
wait which one hold on which one is this
oh my God glitter tiger how much money
did I make this is goodbye man I love
these it's not candy but what can you do
this might be a secret we got a secret
rare yeah cut like it's not even on the
list look at this all right
DM me and uh well I'll accept grade it
Mint Condition yeah all right we're
halfway there all right where where did
the the only fighting thing
oh he's loving it
you will be a strong fighter one day
a little lick all right what about these
let's let's let's do these puree Goonies
let me guess is it yeah it's gummies
yeah you said it but so many gummies so
many gummies these hands these ones are
kind of weird though what
because they like puree oh what yeah
like really weirdly squishy
hmm
I like them yeah these are good they're
really good what the is it Apple
mm-hmm
okay I actually really like them a lot
of gummies like the consistency kind of
gets sucked yeah this is nice they're
like they get like a bit rubbery right
yeah yeah these are nice yeah take care
quite like them yeah
yeah it's pure and natural potato nice
good job Japan branding it's always so
hard to read like words I'm like what
the are they trying to say oh these
slap these are so good
the choo choo oh okay yeah it is
surprisingly I thought I would get sick
of Kevin by now but it's crazy
oh I know these
no not that kind of
you know is it cheongo no no it's gone
they're really soft I do like the sour
yeah these are really good and it says
here one tablet of these has enough
vitamin C for 10 lemons
what 10 lemon oh sorry what's this right
there they love to do that they have
that on the drinks too they're like
don't worry guys this is healthy I swear
to God lemon it's gone like vitamins
right Pirates wish they had this it's
going to be would not be a thing if they
just had one of these
see I've actually bought one of these
ones I'm like mmm candy
and then I read them like one day oh I'm
supposed to have one a day no no you're
not supposed to have water no but I've
read other ones that are like oh yeah
they're not really candy they're just
like vitamins so you're supposed to take
one that's how I unlocked all my Powers
Yeah that's why you turn into a geisha
oh what's this like like that's a spray
isn't it that that's like that's like an
epinephrine like
quickly quickly too much sugar Mega Mal
spray candy
spray candy have you ever had that no
what I've never had this what is it have
you had this spray candy for sure yeah
the gimmick candy we had it growing up
was the the ring that was like a giant
Diamond do you remember that one ring
pops oh Ring Pops sorry
or the spray candy was like another
gimme candy what the I've never
seen spray away bro like in my mouth
yeah no
he never has
[Laughter]
I give myself a spray candy anime every
morning
I give us a couple
oh lovely
all right hit me up bro
[Music]
that's fun
I love it it's really not it's like it's
great flavored spray it's pretty epic
yeah it's all right but eight years oh
my God that's dear Jesus Christ
I love it more of that please no thank
you I'm good I can't eat more
oh actually I think I've we had these in
Australia as well but these are konyaku
oh really yeah
which one do you want do you want yogurt
or grape um I get the yogurt okay the
yogurt so how do you open this without
spilling it everywhere
nailed it oh geez how are you supposed
to do it
oh
just crack it open for them
hey more jelly all right
what do you mean yellow jelly from the
jelly man
[Music]
challenge ew
ew stop it Joe no so
why oh
you can win
it's not very nice it didn't taste nice
it like stopped me in the back of the
floor and it was like
what's wrong with it I like you rate
that one that's a d bro you didn't sleep
on that like that was a deep breath
yes only boys it's the manly Plum gummy
oh plump yeah what makes it manly
I don't know
I think I've ever had these before
oh no it to me bushy yeah oh
but this is like not even a nice kind of
emotion
ah
no these aren't good bro
oh it's so salty why is it salty
because it's a bit bro oh it
gets better actually it gets bad does it
why do they like this everyone in the
comments when I had it last time I was
like oh my gosh you're supposed to eat
it with alcohol eat with alcohol yeah
flavored things I don't know it has like
that artificial flavor to it I don't
know that was weird yeah I didn't like
that tear man yeah gross what's this
oh that's not scared all right let's try
that
oh look at that and it's perfect to
share
with a friend with a friend oh that's
nice
um
that's not bad that ain't bad hey man
I'm usually not a massive Mochi person
but
raminos yeah the ramen day Emoji
actually quite nice I'll give it eight
here no okay
what are you gonna do no nothing I
literally cannot sway any decision in
this video well you can give your
opinion I just won't listen
want to listen or take it into
consideration what would you rate it
it's like a bee all right it's an eight
here all right sir
that's just how it just stop it just go
over kill me
no not even my stomach can stomach me
these are good I I grew up on these are
these actual candies yeah these are
Robinair candies I ate so many of these
like grape yeah like great flavored
dominant there's a really old video on
my channel yeah where I bought a box
load of these crushed it up into powder
and mixed it with water to see if I
could turn it back into soda
and it failed yeah I just got a bunch of
sugary powdery water that I choked on
okay that's a good idea because I always
feel like that's what you're supposed to
do almost when I look at them yeah right
like it comes in a like a Ramen a bottle
so you're like oh you can turn it back
in the room and if you want to put it in
your room no don't don't do that I gotta
be honest we do them I know your
childhood is at stake here and all that
but it just tastes very like like the
cheapest cheapest candy you could get
that's basically what it is
thank you for pointing out that I was a
poor child growing up I appreciate that
Fearless thank you you must have been
really poor dude yeah yeah steady diet
of my boy
they're they're all right as a kid I
would like them yeah yeah I don't write
them as highly as an adult now to be
fair this is salted azuki salted red
bean things I don't know what these are
I've never seen these before do you like
birthday I prefer the white one
wiping like if there's there's red bean
taste and like all the white red beans
yeah whatever it is it tastes better
yeah right yeah
our first hard candy yeah
you seem thrilled
melaga no it reminds me of my grandma
yeah this is grandma candy hey Grandma
why does Grandma's candy shop dude I
love you but why are you like
you're not giving me the experience that
you think you're giving me yeah just
give me a chocolate or something right
no please oh to be fair this one's not
bad
yeah I love it the inside has like a
salty to product oh nice
oh
don't fight into it well I didn't I feel
like Japan like anything they have they
have to make a flavor out of it yeah oh
we got this well there's gotta be our
candy with it yeah it has to be of
course of course so at least three
people are asking for it
oh what
long long man you haven't seen those
those ads no I don't know all right you
gotta watch the long long man
yeah
so this is a ruler on the back it is
it's a ruler it shows you
exactly how long it is this is yeah it
seems about right it's bigger than your
dog all right well how big are you
20 centimeters wow that's two whole
Momos right there you could buy you know
at the convenient you can buy a ruler or
they yeah what are you gonna get but you
could eat this one I'll let you do the
honor all right you want to pull that
out whoa
[Applause]
and then you can punch
sorry I'm not into that so what you do
is you take a bit and you just oh what
satisfying
that's so cool
oh there you go you got it yeah look at
that sorry for slapping you with it no
worries that would be very nice to you
how was it actually it doesn't take that
one not very tasteful it's fun though
you can practice your slopping for this
I'm not doing that what
how did you even do it
well let me get up
it's too dry to flirt there's no way you
can slap time watch me
this is the weird Japanese in you I
don't know this is why I'm Japanese
is this another vitamin okay
this is gummies I guess it's flat thumbs
what no more 3D gummies for you it looks
like a door stopper oh my God it's so
hard
oh Jesus
it's a question why do they shape them
like this oh they gave him a personality
graph so his personality type is a very
energetic um his hobbies are running
really fast through space and his uh
specialty is stretches and ab work
the more you know get your man that can
do all three
why why man same as why does the dog
sniff its own off okay all right because
it can't I don't want to know that
because they can okay choco baby
chocolate baby chocolate baby these are
pretty good it's got the Meiji brain
it's got the Meiji brand so like these
three together what kind of uh they go
to the go-to's those are those are good
yeah
it's not cigarettes marble is just like
this is literally just like knock off M
M's oh okay that's basically what they
are
hmm
there we go it's just chocolate though
oh it's just chocolate but they're
babies
hey there they come in such small chunks
so you know like you know you don't feel
like you're just like eating a load of
chocolate yeah makes sense these are the
same like they're really tiny yeah he's
good though but they're like strawberry
I've actually bought these a couple
times for myself really yeah because I I
made fun of it when I tried it I was
like Japanese school girls buy these on
their way home from school or something
it feels like that dogs yeah it's
packaged like that yeah
but they're actually really good these
are also pretty good too coffee beet oh
let's try them these are like coffee
beans with chocolate
mmm I'm gonna put these on yeah yes yes
yes yes
that's really good all right I'm just
gonna eat one I will definitely buy
those again yeah yeah that's that's
cheer
what the hell did you just say
yeah
how do you get a single one what did you
just say you want some bro yeah they're
good
these are the coffee flavored chocolate
is always good hell yeah
these are actually so good these are all
high up there oh yeah but they're
chocolate no we want candy
okay
what about
haichu yes but this is to bite you this
is some Sour yeah
okay extra lemon flavor
hey more lemon
Japan loves the lemon flavored
things
oh oh it's way softer than us huh yeah
yeah
it feels like chewing on hair a little
bit
hair yeah like so crunchy I've never
chewed on hair before I don't know what
you do in the spare time but you don't
like that no bruh surprising
thought you'd like that it's so soft on
the outside but the inside feels like
crunchy Sandy almost it does kind of
taste like sand all right what about
these these are also classic juicy I
think these have been around for like
close to 50 years or something these are
around when my mom was a kid
mmm
use a burger it always starts good for
me and then it goes down really I do
notice you do that you you're able to
taste things .01 seconds after it ends
in your mouth it's like the first frame
that touches your tongue you just
um
like how are you I'm an optimistic
person like how are you how are you
tasting it so quickly because I no I
just know right away which is my brain I
have strong receptors what can you gonna
make fun of me for that it wasn't good
it's like if I punched you and like the
moment like the first like and skin
touches you just go well I was gonna say
was if I had to be including these two
yeah very similar I would go with these
yeah I would go with these personally
are you getting a little tired of them
a candy yeah I am but think like if your
eight-year-old Japanese little boy oh
I'd be they said we didn't be the dream
I'd be my pants on the spot
all right what about my stomach hurts oh
what about these
these are fitoches
[Music]
they're not made out of fettuccine they
just shaped like fettuccine oh what
this is Italian lemon flavored this is
what it is for you Mama Mia bon appetit
they have to wait a little bit
beforehand yeah okay
make sure it's processing because I
heard the moment you put in your mouth
this is a very small
like your brain just couldn't help it so
you're like a speeding I can't be the
only one who like knows who I like what
I put in my mouth right away I feel like
speed running Food Dude wow this makes
no sense it's like good good bad good
yes that's what we're doing
it what do you rate the
fettuccine
D for
these
next
jelly set this is also Korean I'm so
sick of candy craziness
you have to make it
I ain't making sure at this point it
comes with a frying pan all right well
let's cook it all right let's cook it
all there's two bags of like like pop
rocks
oh there's two bags of Pop Rocks right
yeah and then you put the egg on top and
it sounds like you're cooking it
because the pop rocks will be going like
all right we gotta try that you gotta
try it all right
whoa that's a lot of Pop Rocks and then
you slowly put the egg on top slowly so
it says here slowly put the egg on top
take it out of the pack you should do
the ad for this it's pretty good you
goody gently
oh it's got a little ink do you hear it
it's already going off quickly
we're missing out of the Ace of our
experience it doesn't get the egg out
hi
yeah
look at that dude it's like you're
really cooking an egg how are you doing
it without any heat
and then that's pretty fun actually whoa
Jesus burn your arms too much oil than
that I just gotta get a sound on it
yeah and then the strawberry syrup now
[Music]
all right you know
here you go Joey I'm not an idiot
what it's one big spoon well how do I
even eat it oh do you want it I don't
know yeah why don't you go first okay
it's your video
I don't think that's how you're supposed
to do it
[Music]
the ketchup is really good yeah
it's got that nice savory flavor to it
yeah um
egg as well I think I got some dog hair
in there
that is perfectly cooked yeah Exquisite
egg and it's still sizzling it is
this man been into a I'm getting it
that's indeed all right but it's very
fun ASMR fun look at that it's still
good you need to try that one no I'm
good
it's a carrot
I know you like carrots Joey
is that a well-known fact yeah everyone
guys I don't know if you know this but
that's what we talk about yeah
Joey only eats Carrots is it a weirdo
Joe we only eat carrots yeah Japanese
like really orange complexions
all right I have to be smart for Julie
yeah please look over there
whoa
he's so smart
what is this they're like dude they're
like rabbit pellets
what is it
oh it's all what is it well don't
honestly I don't know Mommy you can have
one
did you like it Momo
out of ten what do you rate it oh okay
oh wow oh my God that was first one is
this candy or is it it's like rabbit
food
carrot and what else it's like I think
it's rice puffs oh yes it is yeah you
just have like a giant mouthful and see
how much of the moisture it sucks out of
your mouth
oh I can't do it let's pour it in I
don't wanna I'm gonna do it
yeah
it's pretty good you just like shoved
his tongue in there
oh you're six to your ton yeah it's
pretty good actually yeah yeah I'll give
them a beat him oh God it doesn't taste
like carrot but that's probably for the
better well maybe you can even shotgun
it if you cut the bottom part here just
why did we buy so much candy I don't
know you would like buy everything
hey look guys more gummies it's I am Pan
Man gummies which one did you get the
grape one I think no what character oh
the main one you got Obama I got middle
she's my favorite oh okay
well that's a little fun they're not bad
actually this is literally made for like
two-year-olds what does that say about
me I don't know but I like this one more
than a lot of the government
these are actually kind of good these
are like you only say that and then
they're like seat here I can't help that
you have a power
there I said it you proud of me I
thought it'd be fun to bring someone on
give me that to eat together and we
can have fun and eat together
Miss jelly again
delish I love that they're kind of cute
and tiny though
oh really it looks so good let's try it
yeah Beach here on my own Suitor detail
my butt is starting to hurt kill
it smells like
ballad ASMR it's like popcorn this can't
be good oh okay this is vegetable oh
no way you like that oh it's it's like
it's like taco it's essentially popcorn
what the there
poor Japanese kids I mean I don't think
kids would buy this if they do then they
deserve to be bullied
what do you write that Sarah
let's get all the gross stuff out of the
way this is
this is uh vinegar oh so this is the
same oh it's a cardboard one oh God it's
all slimy dude
you smell it
hahaha
[Music]
okay damn it oh my God it's dripping all
over me well then get it over
this
this one is actually not nearly as bad
as I thought really yeah I don't think
you'd like this one no it tastes way
better than the other one the cardboard
one was so difficult to chew but this
one you can actually too yeah because
it's wet that's like saying oh yeah with
cardboard is easy to eat than dry
clothes
you can chew through it
so B2 oh and I made a mess this is also
very classic uh squid no but it's spicy
yes apparently a half half of spiciness
yeah one and a half out of three
spiciness
okay this actually looks good
they're not spicy dude get out of here
Japan maybe for kids maybe it's building
up a little bit no no no
sorry there's it's like a when you
breathe through your nose there's like
some spice yeah it hits the back you
throw it but it's not anything that kids
can't eat cute here
I don't know at this point here
so it's like a weird fever dream video
it should be nice but it's awful at this
point all right
sauce flavored
eat it delicious it's good after having
that cardboard anything that I expect to
taste like the cardboard is like
it's good actually no Joey what do you
want to write this one
um more than you you get to decide for
once this is your chance this isn't as
good as I remember almost give it a good
rating come on
I'll give it a
C4 hey Terry days I love it
[Music]
so you didn't like it I don't it's not
as good as I remembered it to be oh
she's up my ass
oh what else is there left
any other child the childhood in the
sounds that we can ruin for you and
definitely not no more gummy Foods gummy
it's the whole fruit
look at that
this is this is a this is the one true
fruit gummy would you like a whole Apple
yes please thank you I'll take a whole
Peach you talk about this like it's
crazy but like I wouldn't know the
difference like what's so crazy about it
oh have you ever seen fruit gummy where
they literally shaped it off to the fur
no there you go
okay crazy
oh it's so soft
wow you
it's like a marshmallow yeah it is
oh a little surprise me in the middle oh
oh not bad that's not bad yeah you
actually judged the flavor and quicker
than me there
you probably yeah
finally I'm not the only one I mean it's
all right like all right you rate it oh
um see all right most sick we've seen I
actually agree oh my God
he never listens to me
what is that prominent I think soft
candies what's the difference between a
soft candy and a gummy
are they not both soft candies
you decide
um
chewing gum no
I would say this is a soft candy I get
it you got me there Japan you gotta try
it and do it damn it you made me eat my
words I would definitely think this is a
chewing gummy version yeah
more remedy looking things tandemina is
this the fettuccine fettuccine no
it's come to mean
a condomina
they're just like the fettuccino yeah
all right very much
[Music]
hmm
it's kind of like a texture of an actual
grape yeah it's like it has a skin yeah
I think that's what they're trying to go
for oh it feels like eating a grape yeah
what the that's kind of fun 80.
because it was fun I was gonna say
YouTube
would you like a pack of rabbit pellets
oh that looks like fish food yeah it
does
you gotta eat with a stick you savage
what stick it comes with a stick inside
what do you want it comes with a steak
you eat with a stick all right go for it
does it change your experience yeah
you're so fast
I know if I put something in my mouth I
don't want someone to no it's
not that weird that's not weird it's
like watching a speed run hmm
it's like first available frame you
react
I don't around with flavors yeah
clearly thank you
88.80 nah dog that's like a d for me
that's all right it's probably more
like seat here
but it was funny with a stick and I
think Joey's missing out
a lot wow you're gonna put it two whole
points up because it came with a
toothpick really maybe all right we're
speed running now two at a time all
right this is yogurt flavored Shady
money and this is
funny it's just pop rocks I think what
that was mixed pop rocks with candy
well now you can't eat it and it's all
right I'm gonna have whatever this small
straw city is that's pretty good
yeah hey
that's really good yeah yeah I mean it's
PAW Patrol no but they mix it with candy
that's pretty cool you should try this
thing now all right whatever this thing
is
too bad
I don't know I've never seen these
before are you all good flavored yeah
not bad I like a yoga foreign it's a
weird texture I like it it's like
crunchy and soft at the same time yeah
for all 9 000 tastes
that was actually pretty good
um me too
I feel like you don't think I'm
consistent with my rating no I feel like
you've put everything in the BT so far
it's gonna be it's just like
everything else is empty and the beaters
boom yes
that's good these are good all right
don't even need to eat those
good job
never had it again
why do you have to buy so much to it
[Music]
from variations though then
whoa
filled with flavored flavorful every
flavor every every flavor no it's like
every soda no I'm gonna no everything no
dare I sing
beat here
you know
stop pushing the beaches be there all
right
so well thanks for coming along yeah no
worries so I'm gonna go to the hospital
now my stomach hurts I definitely have
diabetes we feel like the two neighbors
kid at Halloween or something
it's like I could have all the candy I
want three days later just lying in a
pool with their own vomit
well thanks for coming along yeah no
worries what was your favorite one
I think honestly like it's not candy but
like these are really
good yeah these are really good I mean
someone actually get like again but
chocolate you can't really up that
much sure so but out of the candies I
honestly I honestly think the tough
gummies I can't believe he's a tough boy
see this is where I can't buy though
because yeah everyone's gonna make fun
of me so are you feeling a little tough
today with your tough gummies
I feel like I can chew it with my mouth
oh by myself
I want to get that strong jawline I'm
ready
honestly if anything's gonna give your
Ginger Chad chin it's eating a packet of
these so kill me you may get that tough
gummy what's your favorite mine are
probably uh the Nerds gummies uh that I
bought for myself these are absolutely
delicious uh I'm glad I found these I'm
gonna take these off myself also talked
to uh goated drink great green tea makes
you lose weight as well oh yeah you got
there I got the lose weight
definitely works
all right well check out Joey and uh see
in the next video bye bye bye